[Musique]
bonjour nous sommes florine et alex ans
on est les réalisateurs de dormez je le
veux le film qui sort le 14 mai en
avant-première au cratère de
saint-arnaud
à la base ce film c'est une pièce de
théâtre de georges feydeau qu'on a joué
très longtemps avec notre troupe de
théâtre c'est net et sans bavure on
était censé la jouer pour la deuxième
fois au festival d'avignon en 2020
festival qui a été annulé pour locaux
vides et du coup un peu frustré tout ça
on a décidé d'en faire un film on s'est
dit pourquoi pas donc on sait associer
tous les deux autres comédiens de la
troupe alexandre guider et on a fait un
scénario pendant tout le temps du
confinement qu'on a écrit bien sûr on
skype à la fin du confinement le le film
était écrit est prêt à tourner et du
coup on a tourné en remplacement du
festival d'avignon en juillet 2020
[Musique]
et ça c'est juste un c'est un valet qui
a des dons d'hypnose et qui s'en sert
pour faire faire toutes les tâches toute
la maison à son maître bourrique et donc
cool la vie tranquille et paisible sort
guère aujourd'hui choisi seulement un
jour bourrique et décident de se marier
quand justin découvre ça il va tout
faire pour faire capoter le mariage
pouvoir garder pour toujours en fait
sont mettre à son service
on a vraiment hâte d'avoir le retour de
du public des gens qu'on connaît des
gens qu'on ne connaît pas le retour
positif négatif également mais surtout
on va nous améliorer en tant que bas
en tout cas réalisateur que médine en
tant que caméraman mon pote toupet
qu'est ce qui s'passe laissent humilier
[Musique]